i can't blame it
again all right
you gotta pay for me
[Music]
boys and girls 62 years ago my core
commander john a logan
issued an order that this 30th of may
should be used as a memorial day
in honor of the soldiers that fought
during the civil war
and every year since that we have been
observing this day and spread all over
the country the boys and the girls the
men and the women everywhere
are scattering flowers all over all the
graves
it began this morning when the sun rose
and it spread all over the united states
until there are over millions of graves
dry and the flags are flying and the
flowers are being distributed
and everybody is happy over the great
wall of the rebellion
[Applause]
[Music]
all right go ahead all right
uh i don't know whether you ever heard
of this experience
i've done picket duty oh that ain't the
truth i'll tell you another one
[Music]
you're taking the chicken along
and it wouldn't stop when i told them
doing my shoving
next night there was two fellows coming
along on my hands and knees and it
wouldn't stop and i
i shot that
[Music]
then about two months after put on the
same boat but you wouldn't brave it it
would stay for us come
they shot along
i'd have to say something
that
is
how would you say it was connie 47.
that's what i thought you saw you don't
believe that we're all right
keep it up
[Music]
if i wanted
[Music]
you